Will your state-at-home care offer genetic closely for non-cancer folk?
So our state-at-home care
So I so understand our clinic the way we operate is everything is at a distance. We've done that for years
So we've done genetic closely at a distance for gosh, probably ten years. So
There's no need there would be no need. There was never a need to cover the office for closely to go over a person's DNA
So we always did that at a distance. We always have done genetic closely
for non-cancer patients as well. So yes, you can
purchase our
That also comes with what was a course on what I
Created multiple lots of lots of videos of the genetic pathways
Sure, I have a lot of them available
Outside of the course on our blog post and our videos website as well
But the I put those videos in a course to help a person understand their genetics
So we use a company called DEA supplementation to run genetics because it gives you the broadest
base of
picture of genes
This was a question I think last time
About genetics and using different. There's a lot of different genetic companies now
And there's a lot of them that'll say
Here, it's $250 to get a genetic picture of for
Possible weight loss help or for possible food allergies or for possible
You know pick the condition
I'm not in favor of those
Our genetic picture looks at all your genes and then I
We give you that
Whole full genetic picture read out. So when you do genetics with us
We give you the whole genetic picture read out which is called a whole genetic report and it's about
350 pages. It's over well-me
So we try to break it down so then we give you what I go through all of that and I'm the one who goes through it for a person and
types out a
genetic
Summary so that's about 20 pages long so we give you a genetic summary so
Go ahead look at your full genetic report, you know for fun and you really want to nerd out on all your genes
But then look at your genetic summary because these are the genes that we need
You know to be concerned with that could be issues
That's still a lot of pages and I also give you another
Report that's called your genetic action steps. So it's really
You know based upon everything that's going on these really should be your action steps in my opinion
And you get all that data with our genetic report. I
Don't the other reason why I don't like those genetic reports that say here run this genetic report for
You're trying to lose weight. You just will tell you the genes that you need to
Support if you're if you're having issues with losing weight
It's because there's a lot of
Half-truths with that
So your genes
Issues if you have defects in your BDR your vitamin D receptor genes. You're going to probably have issues
Holding vitamin C absorbing vitamin C utilize in vitamin. Excuse me vitamin D and you if you ran a vitamin D
Blood test to see your level of vitamin D. You'll notice that it's low even if you're taking vitamin D
Well, if you look at somebody's blood test and their vitamin D levels are low
It's and they don't have genetics done on them. It's pretty good chance that they have
Defects in their BDR their vitamin D receptor genes
So knowing that you have defects in those genes it might be a good idea to take extra vitamin D
So there are action steps that a person could take looking at ones genes
But you can't say oh, I am obese because of my genes nor can I say I have
Constant infections because of my vitamin D receptor genes. Well, there's factors that play into that
Yeah, if you had a higher level of vitamin D. Would you be able to fight off viral infections more readily?
Sure, so there's action steps that you can take based upon your genes
But your genes don't make up your life per se it's it's much more of an epigenetic factor that makes up your
illnesses or lack their abs that it is your genes
But we do think it's important to look at ones genes because it looking at ones genes
It gives you ideas of things that you can support. Let's say if I have a lot of defects in my
phase one
Detoxification pathways in my liver that it is a good idea to support those
Maybe that's why I'm a slow detoxer. Maybe why don't get rid of things as fast as my wife does and I end up with liver issues or
Possibly cancer issues, so knowing
Your genetics can be beneficial, but it doesn't shape your whole life
so
It certainly no way in your genetics is not going to say you have specific food allergies
But it says hey if I have HLAG defects then I have a greater propensity to having
allergies to gluten and dairy and things like that, but that doesn't mean I do so
I think it's better to take a bigger look at your genes
What I always say a 30,000-foot view of your genetics and look at all of them
It's you know they interplay and it or act and then treat the person make suggestions and how to care for the person based upon that make lifestyle suggestions based upon that
another example
I think ill
advice
wrong advice around genetics has been
For those who have some information on genetics would be the
methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase genes the MTHFR genes
Those of us who are some of the first genes that were recognized in many times
I'll have a patient come to us and say hey, I have a double allele defect on C
MTHFR genes so I have to take methyl groups and so I'm on methyl folate and I'm on
methyl comolovated and I have it all these issues well
if a person only ran those if a practitioner
only recommended getting a genetic test that had those in the mix and not some downstream genes in the mix
You can actually do more harm than good to the patient
um because you could be overbethylated the patient
because they have that MTHFR gene defect you think that they need more methyl groups
they're overbethylated and because you didn't look at the big picture of their genes
and they have defects in their biopterate pathway which can lead to emotional issues and serotonin
issues and all sorts of problems
So long answer to this question but yes, we do genetic testing and yes, we do genetic
um
counseling if you want to say that support for people based upon their genetics
and yes, you know doing it in a distance is really the way to do it
but you want to get genetics done where you're going to see as many genes as possible so you
can see the whole mix up how they interact because your genes are simply
ways that your body makes proteins and makes hormones and makes things
but that's what your genes do and we want to look at how those all interact
from a physiological standpoint
oh hopefully that wasn't too long. I hope nobody answered the matter